π την πρώτη να γωνιστική να στήνα μου τους γιατηδες τώρα να που πείσωδεν και
με με στις μαθες πιον κα τε χρεούτε ζητώ και παρα θα κφτε πλέω ναάρα
δεν κάθατώ το πράγματ τηστυχώς πέει και πρακό δ φερον είναι μεγάλο νας για για
την κύρο ι ότι τοπο δόσφερο το πιας σε όλ που την ανικίνηλικία καιέχρα φτάσοε
στε πρώτη κατηγορία αν είι ένα είναι ένα είναι το άθλημα το πιο αγαπη τώ
άθλημα στη χώρα μας και ίναι είναι των το πράμα το οίον πράφυση τους νέους
έξω που τπου τον ίτες κακές τες συνήθειες ούλες τά τηλέφωνα τα αρκωτικά γεπος ανητώπηκι
ο το καθεξί αλλά τούτι ενέ ι πρέπει να έχουν και κάποιον κινήτρο για να
πναπέξου άα που μέ τα γήπετα κιατά λεβάος αφού δεν έχουμε κήπεδα ουμε χώμα έχωματερές
ταθαμε στη πράαν όλιπώς ππάπρώτε κατηγορέία του χροσι που να νέσει ημέρω άδη τώνι το
πράμα ας πούμε πρέπε ν δα πρώτερεότητα ττου κράτους δ πέ κοωνές για τον πρόεδο
της δημοκρατίας τον νίκο χριστό δουλδη ναι ίσουν έναάτομο το οποίον ετάχθηκε ναιουτς πρώτες μέρες
της υποψηφιορητάς αι ίσουν δίπλα σήμερα ια ι σχέσει ου με τον νίκο χριστοδουίδη ναι
πωςόπως εφάεναι και ενα ργότερα και όπουπου το φιδία ότι όλι γνωρίζεται που έγινε τή
προκλογική του φιία και πως να πάμε σε λίτιπο αναγάληπσαφιλέ ενώ πάε κι μπορα να
σου πότει ο κόσμος είχε γιαμένα ένα νάξιμον ο παραπάνω κόσμος έσ το κρέβω ότη
σήμερα νιώθομο μια ντεράστεα αγάπη μου τον κόσμο και ότι νιώθο παντού όπου πά πάω
το εστεατό όριον πάρα αυκό πα στοροπλάνω πάω στο λεωφορείο ωόπου και να πάω κόσμος
αγκαγιζειζει με κού πάνω φωνάζει ευκάλιφωτο ροφέα μαζί μμου και α λιπάρ κάτι πό τ
το περίμενα των το πράγμα ντά συμβήδικς πουκαι λέγου πως γίνεται ένας προβληματικός άνθρωπος σαγκιμένα
να φτάσει σε των σε των το σημείο ναιλοιπόν και φένεται ότι τούτο το πράγματούτ
φήμη τούτη πελάρα τούτι δύναμη επίεμπας το χριστοδουλίδη έτσιμετας